our 8 news now investigators obtaining
body camera video from the crash that
killed liquor store chain owner Kenny
Lee documents revealed Lee was driving
with a blood alcohol level nearly three
times the legal limit eight news now
investigator David charns here with the
new video David yeah and Kirsten we do
want to warn you that these images are
graphic as they do show the scene of the
crash that did kill Kenny Lee as we've
reported Lee was driving a van full of
high-end Liquor on U.S 93 in Northern
Nevada when he crashed into a truck
police say Lee was not wearing a seat
belt in that he was drunk now among the
videos we obtained from State Police is
this conversation between Troopers about
an issue Lee reported the night before
one Trooper saying he had helped Lee
with a tire issue the night before this
crash so my concern is
I feel that there's nothing no issues or
tires on the van yeah because you got to
write your flat last night
and I caught that call the toe Forum
okay so I'm wondering if
the tire for them you know what I mean
did these people said that he was just
kept coming over in their Lane without
drifting yeah he like drifted in there
Lane
drifting into the lane he says their
police had said Lee experienced a tire
issue but they said it was resolved it
did not play any into this crash
anything into this crash at all they
also say that none of the tires on that
van showed any signs of malfunction two
people in the car Lee slammed into they
went to the hospital the bottles of
high-end tequila Lee was transporting
that you saw there on the ground go for
upwards of 200 each Kirsten thank you
David Lee's Discount Liquor owns 23
stores across our state
Kenny Lee's death in November 2021 came
less than three months after his father
and founder of the chain passed away at
the age of 79 after a battle with
pancreatic cancer